mentally I think that all most guys a
good guy you know good guys we are good
guys yeah I agree no um but the thing is
it's about have we found the right woman
okay so if you're with the right woman
then it works if we're not that it's not
yeah but how does she see it though and
she's not going to see it like okay
easily because it depends on who she is
all right this is what I just said to
Pearl it's about to walk but she doesn't
understand do you see me saying it from
a man like
in order for a man to be a good man you
have to have a good woman because the
woman will put you in line like man on
their own don't put themselves in line
we do reckless things we buy we spend
money recklessly we live recklessly and